he's Diana here
she had called me and asked for advice
on a mission she said we're coming
did you know I think they're on the loop
good afternoon I'm Joanne Myers director
of Merrill House programs and I'd like
to welcome our members yes and c-span to
the Carnegie Council and our author in
the afternoon series this afternoon
we're very pleased to have with us
Nicole Pope who recently published her
book Turkey unveiled and she'll be
discussing it shortly Turkey defies easy
categorization its history is complex
for it is a country which straddles two
continents has elements that look both
to the east and to the west yet despite
its modernization and economic and
security ties with its neighbors to the
west European nations have never
considered Muslim Turkey to be one of
their own
in recent decades Ankara as repression
of the Kurds and conflicts with Greece
over Cyprus have only reinforced
European doubts meanwhile Turkey's
neighbors in the Middle East have looked
with skepticism at Turkey's westernizing
efforts its membership in NATO and its
military alliance with the US and Israel
to gain a better understanding of this
vast and important country which lays
claim to being the bridge between Europe
and Asia have invited Nicole Pope who
with her husband Hugh Pope of the Wall
Street Journal has written what The
Times Literary Supplement has deemed
quote one of the best accounts of
turkey's recent history unquote she is
here this afternoon to impart her views
of recent developments in Turkey and to
give us a sense of the direction this
country will head in the next millennium
Nicole Pope has spent most of her
working life in the Middle East for the
past 10 years she has been a
correspondent for Lemone and has worked
for Middle Eastern international as well
before becoming a member
excuse-me reporter for Lamone Nicole
worked for the International Committee
of the Red Cross in Baghdad and in
Lebanon she has appeared on MSNBC and as
a regular commentator on several
international radio stations throughout
Turkey I might add that she also has her
own website which she updates every week
with addressing issues about Turkey
please join me in giving a very warm
welcome
thank you very much for coming
well obviously my task has been made
easier in a way by the fact that
everybody is interested in Turkey these
days because the country has been very
much in the news of course with the
capture of PKK leader Abdullah Allen so
I think this is what I'm going to start
with it seems an obvious starting point
although I have to add that I had
nothing to do with agilent's capture
obviously for Turkey it's a major it's a
major success this is something that
turkey in Turkish the Turkish
authorities have been trying to achieve
for many years they've been trying to
destroy the PKK and the capture of its
undisputed leader a figure who's really
never allowed others to come to the fore
is a major success at the same time I
think that it's a major challenge for
Turkey at this stage while it is a
military success now the story takes on
a completely different dimension it
takes on a political and a diplomatic
dimension and Turkey is going to have to
play and play it very very well in order
to avoid getting into further trouble
diplomatically I'm thinking mainly of
relations with Europe which have been
pretty strained in recent months and
could easily may be made worse if in
coming weeks and if the trial of
Abdullah Ocalan is not handled in a way
that is deemed satisfactory by the
international community now what are the
options for Turkey that I think that's
probably the most positive element I
wanted to stress and I think it's a good
starting point if only the Turkish
authorities could seize it when you
think that for 15 years there has been a
conflict raging in southeastern Turkey
that on both sides about 30,000 people
have been killed
it is quite extraordinary that there has
been almost no incidents of
inter-communal fighting the problem is
clearly not at the
of the society it is not a problem
between Turks and Kurds it is a problem
between the the state and the political
establishment and political Kurds but it
is not an ethnic conflict and I think
that if if you take that as a starting
point it should provide the way for a
peaceful resolution a peaceful way
forward now there are obstacles too to
any positive steps in the resolution of
this conflict one of them one of these
problems is the fact that the Turkish
authorities have never really recognized
the Kurdish problem which they call the
southeastern problem as being having
much to do with anything political or
even ethnic rights they see it mainly as
being a a problem of social economic
development or under development rather
and on the other hand a problem of
terrorism with this guerrilla movement
that has now been very active for the
past 15 years there hasn't been any real
recognition certainly not in a
consistent way of legitimate demands for
the Kurds in Turkey
the conflict has evolved over the years
I mean I think that it had it was at its
peak in the early 90s and around 92 93
when really the PKK had made some
headway had managed to control almost
parts of the southeast where at least
disrupt life to such an extent that it
was almost impossible to live normally
everybody would disappear immediately at
dusk because it was so dangerous to to
be out at night now in recent years the
trend has changed the Turkish army has
taken on a much more proactive role it
used to just barricade itself in its
barracks at night and just hope that
nothing would happen until the morning
but in the past few years it has taken a
completely different role and it
actually trained commander commanders
who went into the mountains after the
guerrillas and as a result the PKK has
been weakened considerably in fact I
think that although our talents capture
is still a major coup to a large extent
the PKK had already run out of steam as
a military as an armed guerrilla
movement and I think that even though
Jalan himself had recognized this
because if you look at his statements in
the past couple of years
not only did renounce claims to
independence but also he was trying to
portray himself much more as a political
figure and he was trying to move in that
direction now of course you the Turkish
authorities at this stage have to clear
choices I think one is to decide that
they've dealt with terrorism they've won
a military victory and therefore it's
the end of the problem all that remains
to be done is to develop the region
economically and currently this seems to
be the route they are taking this does
not however tackle the core issue which
still remains unsolved I think that
despite the fact that Kurds in Turkey
are much less militant than they were
partly because they've been crushed I
mean the repression has been harsh
during the conflict they've really
suffered quite a lot and at at this
stage they are very depressed they do
not they feel that the world has
abandoned them so I think it would take
very little in fact for the government
to initiate this reconciliation that is
much needed I think that it would take
just a gesture they could lift the state
of emergency or they could give some
cultural rights I think it would take
little for the people to realize at
least that the state is now on their
side and has heard them so far these
signals have not come I mean it's still
early days
was arrested only ten days ago I think
that one of the big test is going to be
the upcoming elections on 18th of April
now there are two elections happening at
the same time on the one hand we have
the national elections and obviously
they're the stakes are high because it's
it's it will be about who forms the next
government but for the Kurds there's
also the local elections the elections
for the mayors in all over the country
and this election takes on a particular
importance for the Kurds because in
southeastern Turkey there's effectively
only two parties in the running
one is the pro-kurdish party had up
which the state accuses of being having
organic ties with the PKK and is
currently trying to shut down the other
one is the pro Islamic party the virtual
party which is also very popular now the
Turkish authorities like neither parties
so they're a bit stuck as to how they're
going to play it I think there is little
doubt that if had app is allowed to run
let's say freely and smoothly they will
probably capture the municipality of
several major town in the southeast now
this could you know make the state a bit
uneasy on the other hand I think that it
could also provide a wonderful
opportunity for this party which has
essentially until now being a protest
party with just one cause to be
integrated into the mainstream because
once you're elected mayor of a place the
only revolution you can implement is the
revolution in the way of collecting the
garbage and running municipal services
because once you're there that's what
people expect from you so this would
allow for the party to become integrated
and start representing something else
apart from justice protest
vote but also it is I think at this
stage still important for the the Kurds
to feel that you haven't abandoned their
claims for their own identity although I
have to stress that really at no point
in this conflict has the majority I mean
that there hasn't been any opinion polls
but all the people who go there
regularly know that the the Kurds in the
region never really had a claim for
independence they wanted their own
identity they wanted more local power
but they didn't really seek independence
but I think it's important that they
still have a channel to express their
views now this this is one issue that
the Turkish authorities will have to
handle very delicately the other one of
course is a jallands trial the trial in
itself is considered suspect by most
Western observers because the judicial
process is done by the State Security
courts which is it's an institution that
does not really exist in most Western
countries it's a court that is semi
military with one of the judges being a
military judge and this is this is a
court that handles most crimes deemed to
be political that have to do with the
security of the state or any crimes that
threatens the nation as such so
immediately there is already this
problem about the court itself being not
quite right in the eyes of international
community and of course it's there's
also the whole question about of how is
going to be represented initially some
Dutch lawyers who wanted to represent
him were turned back when they arrived
in Turkey the some of his Turkish
lawyers were South received so many
threats that they have resigned already
and although some were given access to
him they were only allowed to talk to
him for 20 minutes about his health in
the presence of a judge
and Turkey has also reacted rather
negatively at the idea of having
international observers to to to follow
the trial the the trouble of course the
turkey at this stage is that while the
capture of Jalan is a great success it
is also to some extent done exactly what
the Turkish authorities have been trying
to do to avoid for years
they've been trying to keep the Kurdish
issue as a purely domestic thing that
needed to be solved internally and with
the arrest of Virgil on this trial that
everybody is going to follow and Kurds
demonstrating all over Europe it's going
to be very very difficult for Turkey to
argue that it's a purely internal matter
because this is although the so far the
Europeans have I mean the Kurdish issue
is such an hot potato that no one is
very keen to tackle it this was obvious
in November when adalynn was first
arrested in in Italy and nobody wanted
it wanted him I mean the Italians just
didn't know what to do with him the
Germans who had an international arrest
warrant out for him in fact withdrew
their warrant because they were too
frightened of what might happen if he
was actually extradited to Germany where
there's a large population of Turks and
Kurds so the Europeans have not really
come up you know with anything either
for the Kurds or in fact for the Turks
so far they've they've been trying to
avoid the issue but of course the while
the Kurds have become less militant in
Turkey they've become increasingly
active in Europe there is a very
well-organized Kurdish diaspora in in
Europe and this is again the other side
this side that is going to prove could
well prove a thorny issue in a problem
for the turkey for months to come as
we've seen after adilyn's rest these
these groups were able to mobilize large
numbers of demonstrators and very short
notice
there
some violent incidents and the fact that
violence is now spreading to Europe of
course makes it even more of an
international issues so it's going to be
very very difficult for Turkey to
negotiate this this turning point but I
think it is it is a very crucial one and
of course Turkey if Turkey could let go
of this fear of the country being
partitioned if any concessions are made
to the the Kurds this constant fear of
dissent that has blocked any progress
towards more democratization and better
human rights this could also be a new
starting point and as I said the
elections are going to be important not
just for the Kurdish issue but it's
they're going to be important for a
number of other issues the other one
being the issue of political Islam
because once again despite two years of
you know actions by the sort of campaign
against the Islamist by the the secular
establishment the Islamists in their new
formation because their party was closed
down a year ago they reformed they
formed a new party and they're expected
to do almost as far as one knows at this
stage it looks like they're going to do
as well as they did in 1995 so clearly
that there is support for these people
even though the establishment has not
wanted them to integrate into the system
so they their role in Turkish politics
in the years to come and the way the
establishment handles them is is also
going to be a test for Turkish democracy
as I said this is an important time for
Turkey it's a time when things could
really turn around and get much better
but it's good if not played well they
could also make things much worse so I
think that I'm going to take some
questions
thank you very much um could I ask that
you please identify yourself and keep
your question very brief into the point
and just wait until the UM microphone
comes to you please from the internal
problems can you give us some insight as
to recent the developments of the oil
pipeline from trans caucuses going into
but turkey the economic factors and
there is a an oblique influence with the
with the courts since it goes through
close to that area which means possible
sabotage of the lines and so on can you
give us some enlightenment on that place
yes the issue of the pipeline is one
that is a great interest both to Turkey
and to this country I think that you
probably know that the US administration
has put a lot of pressures really pulled
out all the stops when he came to
supporting turkeys case turkeys roots of
this pipeline from Baku to the Turkish
terminal of Jahan the issue of sabotage
hardly ever comes up because it's
obviously not one that is played played
very often played very much but I think
also that the fact that in the region
security has been to large extent
restored compared to what it was a few
years ago I guess they feel that it's
not a major issue but is what seems to
be the major issue is the cost of the
pipeline for the US administration the
Turkish route is one that would a sort
of reduce Russia's monopoly on on the
oil routes and bypass Iran because the
Iranian route is for the time being at
least certainly not acceptable for the
US administration the the trouble is
that while the Turkish route is is a
very politically a very good one it is
also a very costly one and with the oil
prices being so low and ultimately the
power of decision is not just in the
hands of politicians but of the oil
companies
we'll have to pay the bill when it comes
to building the pipeline so there has
been negotiations going on for months
and we haven't really come to any
outcome yet because economically it just
makes it it's a very difficult decision
to take at this stage especially since
the oil reserves are appear not to be
quite as high as was initially expected
the oil prices are low so investors are
very reluctant to put that much money
into the project at this stage any if
there was some reconciliation with the
curve it's on Islam at all and do you
think it's a it's a real threat that
reconciliation could lead to eat
autonomy I I think that you know this
the way to solve the problem I just
don't see this for the Turkish
establishment the concept of giving
rights to the Kurds is very difficult to
accept because they see that with the
number of ethnic groups in Turkey it
would only have open a Pandora's box and
then various group would ask for you
know equal equal rights I think that the
solution will probably come simply from
general democratization of the system in
Turkey I mean in a system that is fully
democratic where people can express
their ideas someone standing up and
saying he's you know he claims his
Kurdish Ness then would no longer be a
problem in itself and in a fully
democratic system you know having going
to evening class in Kurdish should not
be a problem either there's also I mean
for years it's something that has been
on the agenda but never really happened
the concept of decentralization of power
that is a problem not just for the Kurds
but for all the provinces in Turkey I
mean you know I was very surprised for
example a few years ago I visited a
province in
northeastern turkey and these people
were ethnic tax you know but the sort of
discourse I heard there was pretty much
the same thing that I had in the
southeast you know people saying you
know these people in Ankara I do not
understand us they don't understand our
problems we want our people to represent
us so that you know there is this trend
in Turkey so far the center has been
holding back but if this were to happen
if more power was given to all the
regions then automatically the Kurds
would have a greater degree of local
power and that would go a long way
towards solving the problem in your book
it avoid the whole chapter on Cyprus one
of the arguments they thought the
interesting even though it was almost
counterintuitive was that the military
in Turkey seemed to more conciliatory
let's say less intransigent than the the
political leadership in resolving the
dispute which are liberated that well I
think that you know this I think this
was especially the case when shortly
after the intervention in in Cyprus I
mean this is what I think it was general
every and who in his memoirs explained
that they had in fact taken more
territory than they had meant to keep so
that they would have some negotiating
power
unfortunately this you know these
negotiations did not happen immediately
and of course once the territory has
been settled and so on that the whole
issue becomes much more difficult to
solve and right now as you know I mean
the hope of a breakthrough is not it's
not I mean there hasn't been any
anything very new I'm talking I'm
talking about what you know whatever and
said about the time shortly after the
intervention since then a long time as
passed so I think that at this stage the
situation is very very different I mean
it seems that both sides are camped on
their positions and the hope of a
breakthrough I mean certainly now with
the fact that
I was carrying a greek cypriots passport
is not going to do to help relations in
the immediate future so I think that any
hope of an immediate breakthrough is not
immediately you know hello James Bond
I'm interested in the position of bullet
edge of it I mean it seems slightly
anomalous that he should be you know
kind of caretaker Prime Minister and yet
he should score this big victory and I
wonder whether that strengthened him
very much personally and what his
prospects are in the election and also
whether he's in a position where he
might he seems to be the politician most
willing to make openings on human rights
and democratization of things whether
he's in strong enough position to do
anything like that well we'll see after
the elections what position is in I mean
certainly he's been I think he's
probably you know won a number of
percentage points as a result of
agilent's capture how much is not clear
but it is possible that he would be in a
position to form the next government
certainly not alone but perhaps with
Masucci almas enough party weather I
mean yes he is probably you know on
human rights and democratization I think
that he's fairly sincere when he talks
about reform on the other hand he's also
a very staunch nationalist and I think
that on the Kurdish issue if you look at
his statements for example this speech
he made when he called on the PKK
militants to surrender the word Kurd is
never mentioned and so far there hasn't
been any I mean he's always been among
the people who denied that there was a
Kurdish issue he being an old leftist he
saw it as a problem of feudalism in in
the Kurdish region and a problem of
economic underdevelopment so all he
suggested so far is to you know prepare
yet another economic package the Kurds
are very wary of those because you know
every government comes in with an
economic package to develop the
southeast and they
see many results so far that soul is
produced and as I said he's even avoided
the word Kurt so I don't know whether
he's really the one who will be able to
tackle the political dimension of this
problem Chris Pratt ladies vice council
Cypress could you kindly elaborate on
the recent relatively recent Israel
Turkey Israel access and what impact
this will have in the area well this is
this has been going on for about two
two-and-a-half years I think it's it's
it initially it really started as a
military mainly military cooperation
between you know the Turkish military
and the Israeli military very much with
the encouragement I think with of the US
government who is trying to form an axis
or some sort of links between its two
allies in in the region there is also
some attempts to add Jordan to the to
make it some sort of a triangle although
now that the situation has changed in
Jordan it's not quite clear how quickly
these can develop I think that no one in
Turkey you know apart from a few
marginal radical Islam is few people
question the actual relations between
Turkey and Israel although I think
that's at the foreign ministry for
example some people I mean diplomats
some people feel that it should be more
low-key or more discreet the military
have been very very open about it
they've been lots of high-level visits
and it's been diplomats feel that
perhaps it should be kept a bit more
discreet so that it's not perceived as a
provocation by Turkey's Arab and Muslim
neighbors who of course have objected to
the these ties and feel very
uncomfortable about the considerable
power that these two countries put
together could could develop but I think
for the u.s. I mean obviously there's
the two allies there's also I think
perhaps
a way of bypassing Congress perhaps
because at times when it comes to
selling weapons to Turkey there are some
concerns raised about human rights and
things like that and of course perhaps
Israel is a way of bypassing that Arab
states one of the main issues in the
Middle East as we all know is the
problem of water so how do you see this
water affecting relationships between
Turkey on one hand and Syria and Iraq
and even the Kurds because I think the
main source of water flow and the in the
region controlled by the Kurds yeah well
I mean certainly water has played an
important role in in relations between
Turkey and Syria and I think that it's
generally perceived that one of the main
reasons why Syria was backing the PKK
for all these years was as a you know
weapon against Turkey and trying to get
a better deal on the water sharing
agreement now as you know turkeys
involved in building this gigantic
sacral southern Anatolia project which
involves I think it costs thirty two
billion dollars it involves building 22
dams building power stations irrigating
vast amount of land and of course it has
made the turkeys neighbors downstream
Syria and while Syria especially because
Iraq has both rivers so it's a bit more
independent but Syria especially very
worried about Turkey controlling the
flow of water now Turkey has promised
that he'd would always I mean there's
been while they were building the dam
there's been brief periods when the flow
was interrupted but basically Turkey has
so far kept its promise to give 500
cubic meter per second to Syria which is
sufficient for Syria however what the
Turkish authorities have so far refused
to do and what makes Syria very unhappy
and that's where the PKK comes in it's
the fact that Turkey has always refused
to put this down in writing in the form
of a treaty the Turkish Authority
do not want any amount set in stone as
it were because they say we don't know
what's going to happen in 50 years there
could be a drought we may need more
water or whatever so they don't want to
have specific amounts and this has led
to much tension between between the two
countries and you know over the years
when they were negotiating or trying to
negotiate on these things it was quite
obvious that when negotiating
negotiations would falter suddenly that
you would have an outburst of activity
by the PKK I mean there was clearly a
link between the two
Lawrence Clark naval commander very
interesting about Turkey I think
Americans know more about Turkey than
they know about practically any on the
other country and we certainly are quite
grateful to them for holding back the
Russians my my question is with regard
to the fact that there are 10 or 15
million Kurds here in the air various
countries and in various areas of
problems and but I would say or it would
appear to me that the Kurdish problem is
a very small in comparison to the
fundamentalism problem in Turkey my
corector well it really depends who you
ask
I do not I I do my personal view is that
I do not view the so called
fundamentalism as much of a threat in
Turkey personally because I think that
it's important to see that there are
various trends in Islam that there are
various interpretations in Turkey even
historically even during the time of the
Ottoman Empire has always had a very
modern moderate form of Islam and
I think that you know if you look at the
past few years when the Islamists have
become more powerful politically they
haven't really done very much that
suggests that they you know that they
are revolutionary in any way I mean
certainly you know I'm not saying that
they are wonderfully democratic and
should be handed power what I'm saying
is that they can be integrated in a
society and that they should in fact be
integrated in the political system and I
think that the society can quite easily
absorb and control them tell us
something about the Turkish economy for
example what does Kirk took he shouts
the world to pay for imports sorry
itself to the world well every country
if you want to pay you want to import
goods from other countries has to shell
what does turkey producing export Oh
turkey produces and exports a lot of
things I mean textiles is a very yeah
textiles are a very big Turkish export
of course tourism also brings quite a
lot of revenues is an increased number
of tourists coming into the country but
nevertheless the Turkish economy which
had really had a boom for four years you
know with growth rate of up to eight
percent is has in recent months suffered
a bit from the I mean not only because
it has its own structural problems that
it has failed to tackle very
successfully so far but also because
it's these structural problems make it
vulnerable to outside shocks and of
course there's been the crisis and in
Asia there's been the crisis in Russia
especially that has affected the Turkish
economy because trade and
exchange with Russia will quite quite
important to the Turkish economy so
right now the Turkish economy is
stagnating and of course the inflation
has been rampant for years I mean this
last year they managed to reduce it from
97 percent at the beginning of 1998 to
50 percent at the end of the year but
even at 50 percent it remains very very
high by most countries standards and the
fact that Turkey as an emerging market
is also suffering from the lack of
confidence in emerging markets all over
the world these days so it finds it more
difficult to borrow abroad and in order
to finances itself it borrows internally
from in the domestic market at huge
interest rates so it's a very costly way
of financing itself and it's it's
difficult
hello Catherine Gregorio political
scientist I wanted to ask you what is
turkey's expectation from the
relationship with the countries of the
ex-ussr that are its neighbors and
because there's a lot of coming and
going there
what do you would you have to say well I
think when the Soviet Union first fell
apart Turkey had great expectations I
mean they saw the possible development
of some sort of Turkic world weather you
know with the turkey as its center I
think that these past few years have
shown that well things are not going to
develop quite that far but that doesn't
mean that there is nothing there
certainly turkey has close relations
with Azerbaijan it has relations with
all these Turkic republics you know they
do their language do does share a route
but these are different dialects and
they don't actually always understand
each other very well however they do
share a sort of common cultural heritage
and they do feel close to each other I
think that the fact that the Turkish
government the Turkish state is not very
wealthy is also hampered its efforts to
really you know try and help development
although they have you know there are
student exchange programs there are a
few thousand students from these Central
Asian Republics who who are studying in
Turkey what has developed very well
however is not so much these big
projects I mean Turkey can't compare
compete with Chevron or whatever you
know these big companies that can pour a
lot of money into the region but small
and medium enterprises I mean the small
Turkish and entrepreneurs have gone with
great enthusiasm into these countries
and of course at the beginning the
conditions were often quite difficult
but these are people who are you know
that there is really an entrepreneurial
spirit in Turkey and these people would
go out and even though the
additions were very hard managed to
build a business there so there are a
lot of these small and medium companies
medium-sized companies all over Central
Asia and so the Turks have established
the presence in that way oil I mean yeah
we were talking about the the pipelines
yeah but they're again you know Turkey
canola is only a minor player in the
sense of developing oil fields and
things it's not really in in running the
oil root system the main way of Turkey
to get some sort of some degree of
control or some you know a stake in the
deal the flow of oil to to the
international market and take some of
that away from Russia which until now is
pretty much controlled most of what goes
out given the push by the Islamist
parties for political power I would like
you to comment on the likelihood or the
the possibility of changes in the rather
strict sections of the Turkish
Constitution which absolutely prohibit
any non secular activities by the
government or the Toleration of non
secular activities in the government yes
I mean that is it does go ahead on I
mean that's where you know you you have
different interpretations you have the
sort of the real secularists who say you
know democracy has the right to protect
itself therefore these people threaten
democracy therefore any methods used
against them is justified because
democracy has to protect itself there is
the other view which would say that
these people can be integrated into the
system and what blocks them blocks
democracy all together these limitations
on the way women should to dress to go
into Parliament for example
are they justified or not I mean this is
but so far the establishment has shown
absolutely no willingness to change but
this for example this is an issue that
may well come up after these elections
now what happens is that the Islamic
party is going to have women candidates
for the first time now they they have
played it carefully they had they have a
few candidates who do not wear the veil
and these are in better electoral
positions so they're probably going to
be the ones elected first but they have
nevertheless decided to put put up some
candidates who wear the headscarf these
are less well placed on electoral lists
but if they were to be elected it's
going to be a very interesting question
I mean there's nothing in the law that
prevents them from running into the in
the elections but there is a law that
prevents them from entering Parliament
actually entering the building with a
headscarf so if they are elected it's
going to be an interesting situation to
do anything once it gets into a position
of power within the Parliament they're
going to have to change the Constitution
oh yeah I mean that was my question how
do you see the likelihood of that
happening I mean I don't you know it's
it requires you to change the
Constitution you need two-thirds of the
parliament so for the Islamic party to
be considered to be in such a position
now I can't remember the exact figure
but I think it needs to get 36 or 37
percent of the vote to get to that
position and it's far from that and in
fact I don't really see it ever coming
to that to that point because it's you
know it's constituency seems to be
between 20-25 percent but I don't see it
coming to power and suddenly changing
the Constitution
I think that even if it comes to power
it will always certainly for the time
being it would be within a coalition or
it would not be it would not have a free
rein and be able to suddenly turn the
regime around overnight
certainly not absolutely yes that is the
key issue you student from Istanbul I
just happened to be here and I'm very
glad to be here because hope has
wonderfully and very objectively has
talked about her observations about
Turkey there is only one point I don't
really actually agree with you that's
the threat of Islam fundamentalism and I
think the gentleman was right when he
said I think it's much more important
than the Kurdish if you pour the Turkish
population hmm and it has so many social
social and cultural background about it
I mean it would take it two hours three
hours to talk about it why they can in
the future if we're not careful take
over slowly they have lots of financial
backing from other countries which is
very important in today's world and they
can go very very wisely and in the
underground let's say that they have I
mean because I'm working for him for two
associations who are pro atatürk
associations for secularism and we have
followed maybe for the six seven years
what they have been doing which we
cannot do because if you believe in it
if you're real a fundamentalist you
agree with everything that the head
tells you and if they ask you for
anything you can even die for them
that's the scale
thing about it it's not for the
Democrats like that I mean we talk in
our clubs in our meetings and we don't
come to a resolution
but they say 100 women will go from one
house to the other house tomorrow asking
for donations and they do this so I mean
it's not an immediate danger but it is
very important we might be aware can I
comment on this sure okay I I mean you
know I agree with you that I do not I'm
not saying that they should be in power
and they're wonderful what I'm saying it
what I'm saying is that in a Democratic
Society I mean they did not invent the
rules of the elections the Democratic
game this this game they are playing it
in their own way but the other parties
can play too
now the trouble is that the political
system in Turkey is rather dysfunctional
at the moment and I think that you're
you know you may disagree with their
aims but I think that in terms of what
they achieve they are a party that comes
up with a program they are a party that
comes up with real work at grassroot
levels whereas unfortunately the the
other parties the ones we should be you
know supporting secularism but within
the system are doing very little they
have lost a lot of their ideology I mean
if you can tell me what each party
stands for I'd be grateful because it's
it's not quite clear at this stage I
think that the population also feels
that these parties have for too long
being cut off from the Audrey people and
they don't feel that they represent them
anymore so I think that it's rather than
punishing the Islamist party which in
its way is doing its job as a party I
think that it would be more a question
of strengthening the other parties and
encouraging them to do the same same job
I mean you say we can't go down in the
streets and talk to people why not why
the other parties do that that's what I
meant yeah but what I'm saying it says
of course you have to be vigilant but in
the democratic society then there's
nothing stopping the other parties from
doing the same thing and they should be
at this time you would care to discuss
the role of the military yes I mean you
know it's that's an interesting and
delicate issue for of course for the
secularists the military are seen as the
power of last resort the last bastion
that will protect the established order
of course for the people who are
challenging this I mean and I'm not
talking necessarily about taking over
the system I'm just talking about people
who feel that in today's society there
is space for more diversity and not
necessarily this one ideology these
people the military sort of stand in the
way of more of opening the society so as
these two interpretations and right now
I'm in the military play a very very
important role in the political process
they play it behind the scenes I mean
it's not like in 1980 when they actually
took power but nevertheless the Turkish
Constitution which was written and
approved at the time when the military
were in power does give them this this
role through the National Security
Council which meets once a month and
it's it's a meeting of the top ministers
and the top generals under the
chairmanship of the the president and
the National Security Council does not
just deal with security issues but deals
with just about anything from the
economy to the Kurdish problem to
foreign policy and it makes
recommendations to the government
and it's almost unknown for the
government not to follow the
recommendations of the National Security
Council so obviously the military plays
a very important role harvey's Odin from
ABC I'm curious to know about the level
of corruption in the Turkish government
we've all read a lot about it what
effect does that have on the country and
do you think that's moving in the right
or wrong direction well I guess the fact
that it's been so much in the news I
guess you could say is a step in the
right direction
on the other hand I think that most
people in Turkey were quite astonished
by the level of corruption that has been
revealed in the past two and a half
years I mean what really brought the
matter to the attention of the the
public was a car crash in November 1996
when in the same car were I mean there
was one survivor the other were killed
was a police chief right-wing gangster
who had been on the list of Interpol for
years and his girlfriend and there was
also a deputy a member of parliament
from mrs. Chile's party who also
happened to be a sort of Kurdish warlord
who had his own militia fighting against
the PKK now in the cars were also traces
of drugs and some weapons that are
normally used for hits you know not just
a sort of pistol that you might carry
for your own defence so this exploded on
the scene and there was a parliamentary
inquiry there was there were lots of the
press dug a lot - and basically you know
the intricacies of all these links are
just too complicated for anyone to
really follow but basically it revealed
a network where some gangsters I think
were initially they were mainly
right-wing millet
from the pre kuk period were then at
some stage recruited by the state to
carry out some operations underground
operations and later sort of with this
power and the protection of the stage
because they carry diplomatic passports
they had you know they enjoyed enormous
protection then it seems that they sort
of went completely astray and then to
cover the drug traffic and so on
and it also appears that these same
people were involved in the killings of
Kurdish nationalists there's about three
and a half thousand or four thousand
people who were gunned down by
mysterious killing killers over the
years especially in the early 90s and
these people would just be gunned down
in the street or sometimes arrested and
their bodies we found a few days later
now these gangs who are both criminal
but also with some sort of an ideology
appear to have been involved now since
then there's been a lot of other
scandals that have emerged a lot
involving these criminals who seem to
have really a very well-established
network that within the police within
you know various state organizations and
this is in fact what brought down it's
it's such a link that brought down the
government of Masood Yilmaz in last
November when it was revealed that one
man who had bid successfully and bought
a state bank that was being privatized
with apparently the encouragement of the
prime minister had in fact been found to
have had direct links I mean there was
tape conversations that were released
that showed that he had links to one of
these mafia people and I mean basically
there is a high level of corruption and
that of course plays a role as well in
electoral results because the Islamist
party is the one that has played on that
and
the fact that most of the other parties
have somewhat been tainted by all these
allegations does not make that job
easier
my name is Austin list in view of the
controversy over tons of chilla and the
obvious or at least apparent obvious
involvement of her she her family and
her husband in various unethical and
maybe illegal activities how do they
propose to retain credibility in the
government when she continues to have a
position in the coalition government in
your view what is her future well she
seems to be making a comeback she's you
know she seems to be doing quite well in
the opinion polls I think that you'll
find that you know message Alma's I mean
he's not in power but he's backing the
current government of edge of it and he
may well find find himself in the next
government if indeed edge of it has
enough votes to to be the one forming
the government and yet he fell over
allegations of corruptions in November
there hasn't really been much looking
into and he could very well find himself
in government again so I think that you
you know if you ask anyone in Turkey
you'll find that in the eyes of the
public the only politician who really is
considered squeaky clean is mr. edge of
it was currently in power all the others
are to some degrees I mean tansu chill
air is not the only one all of the
others have to some degree being tainted
most of the others
I'll let you answer mmm Nicole I thank
you for being with us in failing all
those taking place in Turkey today it
was a wonderful discussion and I invite
you to purchase Nicole's book but she
will be selling like this I mean thank
you very much
Oh
yeah she's going to use her hands
yeah
the spider face
again I hope you enjoyed the communion I
just want to say